et bien bonjour comment allez vous chers
amis moi ça va plutôt bien j'adore que
le micro à ma bouche je pense que vous
adorez - par contre les amis hier au
moment où je tourne cette vidéo c'était
le réveillon qui dit réveillon 10
cadeaux nourriture chansons paillardes
de beauf
ouais moi y'en a vraiment qui a lancé
une mais bien plus rare est incroyable
que ça les amis mon père m'a donné un
véritable trésor quelque chose d'une
valeur inestimable plus beau des cadeaux
une pochette remplie des dessins que
j'ai fait quand j'avais entre 5 et 8 ans
a passé plus beau cadeau mois déjà c'est
cool parce que vu qu'il fallait que je
tourne aujourd'hui que je n'ai pas
d'idées mais ça m'a donné une idée
géniale donc merci papa lui en suis je
trouve ça génial parce que je me
souviens de rien du tout donc ça va me
revenir en les regardant j'ai lutté pour
pas regarder excuse moi c'est là les
huit pour pas regarder les dessins qui a
deux dents parce que mon frère a reçu la
même poche est avec des dessins lui et
les a tous regardé devant moi comme
j'avais trop envie d'ouvrir la mine mais
je me suis retenu mec c'est un véritable
trésor qui se trouve à l'intérieur quand
je vais l'ouvrir ça va probablement être
bois ou non je déconne en fait dans la
pochette il y avait une pochette dessin
lui qu'avec c'est incroyable on va les
mater ans entre un parent je lisais pas
scannés donc je dois vous les montrer
comme ça mais bon c'est une petite vidéo
tron qui l'ambiance pekouz à l'arraché
après noël le premier à huy j'adorais
scotché des feuilles pour faire des
dessins comme l'a par exemple olalalala
il est grand sur la la la il est grand
c'est un véritable dragon de la mort ben
je trouve ça pas dégueu je vois juste
pas trop où elle dragon et encore moins
la mort par contre je vois bien où est
la faute d'orthographe ça n'y a pas de
pas de problèmes aux quels c'est un très
beau dragon de la mort voilà les spams
envoyés vos dragon d'abord à vous je
n'accepterai que s'il ya une faute
d'orthographe en menant à bien sûr
hockey dessin suivant juin 99 mais que
j'avais trois ans sa date de juin 99 et
c'est steve hill et je dire laissez
personne vous dire avec blasé lucas
entre guillemets mon papa je suis désolé
papa je vois pas trop où tu es
réellement en tout cas ce que je peux
dire c'est que t'es un gros pénis parce
que ça c'est vraiment un pénis impasse
mentières donc j'ai dû le voir une fois
lieu quand j'étais petit et samassa m'a
impressionné on peut voir qu'elles
peuvent dessiner les pieds comme
maintenant ça ça me fait plaisir et à
l'intérieur et à quoi au poème dans tes
bras de papa
je me sens bien plus grand
un peureux plus heureux je t'adore plus
encore j'ai très mal espagne alors ça
c'est quoi alors ça c'est pas du tout un
dessin papa je te jure que ce que tu as
acheté récemment ça m'intéresse pas de
ouf shakedown lui glisser un dossier en
scred mais je pense qu'à j'espère que tu
auras du plaisir avec ton contrôleurs de
motifs du dôme smart the wise pas pas
vraiment alors haussé m'ignorer une
petite led pour papa à c'est mon frère
qui l'a fait à meille ses troupes est au
c qu'est ce qu'il avait écrit mon frère
hausse et ce à l'aide de nous beaucoup
papa je t'envoie ce que je t'avais dit
que je voudrais pour noël
bisous smac ils voulaient quoi pour noël
attention une voiture télécommandée un
robot rapide et capable de saisir des
objets grâce à ses fins puissante
le succès de la mission est garanti
alors si je puis me permettre crois que
ça a foiré florent puisque je n'ai
jamais vu avec ce robot je crois que le
père dont il n'est pas pressé cette
année-là alors qu'est ce que c'est que
ça ah ça c'est des trucs que tu te faire
je crois la maternelle ou à la crèche
c'est avec des éléments tout pouvait
coller un an fait juste collé des
éléments là où c'était indiqué d'accord
il ya vraiment aucun esprit de création
là dedans c'est juste ça en juin 2001
j'avais 5 ans jetons je comprends je
sais vraiment pas ce qui se passe dans
notre tête quand on est enfant tête
c'est comme ça comme ça comme ça je sais
pas ce que c'est que quelqu'un voit
dragon de la mort là dessus il est pas
la bonne fête papa et mon père c'est
bien des papas quand même il a gardé
tout ce que je lui ai offert c'est ouf
non ok il avait reçu une lettre à
l'époque avec un truc disney dessus
qu'est ce que c'est oh là là à regarder
comme je dessinais déjà très très mal
je crois que c'est un skateur ou un mec
en snowboard ce dessin est nul à chier
papa je suis vraiment désolé tu avais
envoyé des personnages cette qualité
puisque c'est vraiment pas très beau et
audois ya kwa thema mon frère comment il
dessine et derrière la diff déjà dessiné
déjà trop bien le petit bâtard c'est
tellement j'avais pas compris à l'époque
que faire un dessin de cette qualité au
dos d'un dessin de cette qualité c'était
parfaitement millions et ça ne m'était
pas du tout en valeur mais je crois j'ai
voulu refaire le personne mon frère qui
était là la version originale la version
du [ __ ] de pauvres c'est génial
m'avait a précisé à l'ats me lucas mais
c'est tellement évident que c'est moi
qui ai fait lui et son frère café le
dessin trop stylé oddo suivant c'est un
certificat disant que j'ai exploré une
fourmilière à la cité des enfants en
2003 moi je m'en souviens pas quoi
olalalala lors la mecque
c'est noël regarde un peu ce que j'ai
fait à noël un [ __ ] de sapins en
papier qui brille c'est bizarre parce
que c'est à des espèces de flash de très
lointains souvenirs qui reviennent quand
tu vois des trucs aussi vieux c'est moi
qui les fais donc mon cerveau il a foutu
cette info quelque part dans le néant
par exemple et ça me revient
de quoi et je me souviens je n'arrivais
pas à faire un vrai sapin envoyé ça fait
pas du tout à sa fin quoi ça marche pas
du tout et j'ai été triste parce que
j'avais raté mes bons et ma mère comme
d'hab qui précise oddo que c'est moi
mais maman tu crois en floride va faire
ça c'est incroyable et attend ça s'ouvre
olalalala mec c'est cali ou pas c'est
vraiment le standard de l'enfant
l'enfant vraiment écrit comme ça il fait
des trucs comme ça
joyeux noël maman et papa si vous voulez
je vous achèterez un truc bidule
chouette
en tout cas le principal c'est que vous
soyez contents et qu'on ne fera plus de
bêtises florent et moi si vous voulez
nous chanterons les frères jacques
pour se faire pardonner vue sur des
bisous à bientôt
youcat ces unions c'est comme millions
de ces petits enfants ils sont mignons
mec c'est impressionnant aussi à quel
point j'ai écrit pareil j'ai gardé la
même écriture ceux à qui j'ai dédicacé
un tourner la page
regardez l'écriture c'est exactement la
même c'est incroyable premier dessin à
aÿ les pas des genex et kalidou ce mec
c'est un perso de dragon ball z
franchement aujourd'hui si je vais le
refaire je le ferai moins bien mais pour
de vrai rigueur mais que j'ai fait du
détail sur les murs je crois que la
double c'est que je prenais modèle sur
les desseins de mon frère pour faire mes
propres desseins en fait c'était
vraiment juge recopier ce que je voyais
c'est donc du coup c'est un peu s'est
passé regardez ça date de juillet 2003
mais qu'un c'est vraiment vieux os
attention un nouveau méchant après le
dragon de la mort je vous présente le
démon de la morgue du tout il a appuyé
son nid sur la tête mont gao et là il ya
un croquis du dragon de la mort une
première version du dragon de la mort
que j'avais tenté un nouveau méchant
encore une fois toujours avec des
gouttes de 201 qui coupent des armes
c'est très important comme détail à des
bars les yeux je le fais toujours pareil
je ne loue pas évolué au dessus elle est
raillée 2 août mec vraiment là on sait
craquer mec assez dégueulasse ça me fait
des frissons cette même bon bah là on
est complètement parti en couille 1 mais
je crois que c'est un super saiyan
puisqu'elle est norad super saiyan au
tour quand je l'année dbz je voyais ça
en fait je n'ai pas la même vision que
les autres attention première évolution
c'était un tournant de ma carrière après
ça m'avait contacté a en masse pour
m'exposer mais j'ai refusé parce que
j'étais trop jeune et en mylar je
pouvais pas encaisser l'argent donc ça
m'intéressait pas concret maintenant de
l'épaisseur au niveau du bras par contre
au niveau des jambes on est toujours sur
de simples traits mais franchement leur
niveau des bras qui sont à des beats il
ya un effort 2001 va randol autour d'un
feu de bois alors je pense que le terme
farandole c'est vraiment ma mère qu'il
ait il a écrit un voilà à quoi ça
ressemble une farandole autour d'un feu
de bois on est plutôt à un rite vaudou
de gens qui veulent un requin démons
mais bon je suis même des espèces du
livre avec des petits dessins dedans nul
est moche ça se fait que j'ai arrêté je
crois que je m'étais juste mon frère
mais moi je n'étais pas fait pour ça oh
là là une oeuvre d'art [ __ ] mais
prime abord gens sur le ca bonnes années
d'avant j'avais enfin réussi à faire la
forme tant espéré de sapins bon j'ai
juste suivi les instructions de la prof
à l'école mais c'est ok j'avais réussi à
faire ce [ __ ] de sapin mais que
j'étais content plus tard qu'hier j'ai
un truc a encore marqué la mort servant
l'expression des enfants quoi et j'ai
fait un ninja de la mort mais je les
paie t je les paie t'es pas je suis
désolé ah non il en plusieurs parties ok
je vais devoir me poser mais quand on
aime on stranger singh ok c'est bon j'ai
réussi on a donc un dessin en 6 feuilles
ça représente une arme rieuse racaille
de la mort tu en penses quoi
elle se casse non mais c'est d'homme
sahara en bas on a des tombes des toons
extrêmement glossa ca présente de la
neige et le logo nike de manière
méprisés et je marche sur un un cadavre
mais pour montrer que c'est un canal
juste une tête de mort bon c'est là elle
a l'air un peu comme mais bon j'aime
bien les plus téméraires reconnaîtront
l'inspiration très claire de poivre
blanc
les tueurs tracas comme je les appelle
confrères on achetait que c'est du
chantage du coup on dessinait les persos
qui a aidé su acheter un toc - et là on
a une pochette vit donc dans tous
regardés mike d'âge aurait mes carnets
plus les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo
c'était plutôt courant j'aurais aimé
qu'on s'amuse plus le malheureusement il
n'ya plus de dessin on a fait tout ça
quand même mais qu'un a beaucoup
n'hésitez pas la même vie au ciel vous a
plu j'adore la nostalgie les trucs qui
date de 2000 2002 quand j'avais 6 ans 8
ans c'est génial puisque c'est une
période que tu as complètement oublié ta
oublier tout ce que tu as fait à cette
époque et du coup vous tomber sur des
trucs aussi vieux vata des petites
fractions souvenirs qui font surface
comme ça c'est très marrant n'hésitez
pas à mais la vidéo si elle vous a plu
et surtout si vous avez aimé mes dessins
de quand j'avais 6 ans ça fera plaisir
au mois deux il ya quinze ans je fais un
maximum de bisous j'espère que les fêtes
étaient bonnes même si c'était ya une
semaine et que vous profitez bien de vos
cadeaux et à très vite
[Musique]
ça